ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
คุณครับนักเรียน
เย้
กลับมาแล้วกลับมาแล้วกลับมาเจอพี่อาร์ตี้
มันเจอน้องรี่ทำกัดทุเรียนมนโหลสวัสดี
น้องช่อง
เจอกันในช่องคอมเปลี่ยนเซเบิลไทยนะครับ
โอเคครับอ่าวันนี้วันนี้เรามาเจอกันนะ
ครับวันนี้วันอะไรครับวันนี้วันนี้วันนี้
ทัน
วันนี้วันจันทร์วันจันทร์อยู่ตรงไหนเนี่ย
วันจันทร์อ่ะโอเค
ท่านวันจันทร์ที่วันจันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่
ครับวันนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับยี่สิบสี่
อ้าวันจันทร์ที่ 24 ออกโอเควันจันทร์นะ
วันจันทร์ที่ 24 เดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้ดี
เดือนนี้เดือน
1 มกราคม
5 เดือนนี้เดือนมกราคมโอเค
มกราคมแล้วปีขอสอบอะไรครับพ.ต.
2022  5 ปีค.ศ 2010  22 โอเคครับแล้วปีพ
ศ.อะไรครับพ.ต.
2565  2566  5
แยกแค่เดือนนี้เดือนนี้เดือน
R6 อาคมมกราคมแล้วเดือนนี้เดือนนี้เดือน
มกราคมเดือนที่แล้วเดือนที่แล้วเดือนอะไร
ครับเดือนที่แล้วเดือน
ธันวาคมเดือนที่แล้วเดือน
ธันวาคมธันวาคมนะครับแล้วเดือนหน้านะครับ
เดือนหน้าเดือนอะไรเดือนหน้าแต่เดือนหน้า
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
เดือนหน้าเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ว้าวนะครับแต่เดือนนี้เดือนนี้เดือน
มกราคมใช่ไหมมกราคมใช่ตลาคมหรือมกราคม
เหมือนกันคนไทยเรียกสองแบบเรียกมกราคม
เรียกมกราคมเหมือนกันใช่ 5 โอเคแล้ววัน
นี้ครับอ่า
เดี๋ยวนะนี่กำลังกำลังคิดอยู่ว่าเดือนนี้
ตลาคมนะครับเดือนนี้มกราคมเดือนหน้า
กุมภาพันธ์
แม้วแล้วถ้าอีก 2 เดือนข้างหน้าอีก 2
เดือนเดือนอะไรครับ
อีก 2 เดือนอ้ายเดือนนี้น่าได้ครับอีก 2
เดือนข้างหน้า
ถ้าเป็นเดือน
มีนาคม
5 มีนาคมแล้วอันนี้ 1 เดือนหน้ามันก็อัน
นี้
2 เดือนอีก 2 เดือนข้างหน้าเดือนมี.ค.
หาว่าขอแค่ 2 เดือนข้างหน้าเดือนข้างหน้า
ใช่ครับโอเคแล้วอ่าตอนนี้
กี่โมงแล้วครับที่เราเรียนกันอยู่ตอนนี้
ตอนนี้
หา
21:00 นาปะ
5 ทุ่มแล้ว
21:00 นนะ 21:00 นก็ต้องเขียนถ้าภาษาไทย
ภาษาไทยหรือเช็ค 9:00 นได้ไหมอ่ะอ่าๆๆ
อะเวลาเขียนต้องเขียน 3 ทุ่มแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
ครับ 3 แอบซุ่ม 5 เป็น 09:00 นตรงใช่ไหม
ครับใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าเป็นเลข 9 ในการ
และคนใครพูด 3  3 ทรายครับหน้าตรงนี้คน
ไทยพูด 3 หน้าตรงนี้ศ.ของตัวนี้ 1 ไหม
07:00 นเช้า 8:00 น 9:00 น
10:00 น 11:00 นแล้วก็ตรงนี้เป็น
เที่ยงเที่ยงพี่นะเพราะว่าเป็นกลางคืนใช่
ไหมเป็นกลางคืออื่นๆน่าใช้ถ้าเป็นกลางคืน
คนไทยเรียกเที่ยงคืน
พระอาทิตย์กบตกแล้วได้ตอนกลางคืนไม่มีพระ
ทิพย์น่ะพระอาทิตย์ตก
ใช่
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ 9:00 นตอนนี้ถ้า 21:00 น
อาร์พีอีกทีอีก 1 ชั่วโมง
กี่ทุ่มครับอีก 1 ชั่วโมง
อาิตย์ 1 ชั่วโมงทุ่งค่ะอ๋ออีก 1 ชั่วโมง
อ่ะไปอีก 1 ชั่วโมงก็คือ 22:00 นใช่ไหม
อ่า 10:00 น K  A  R  D ครับแล้ว
ar3 ชั่วโมงที่แล้ว 3 ชั่วโมงที่แล้ว
เวลาเท่าไหร่ครับสามชั่วโมงที่แล้วได้
ครับบบโมงอ้าว 6 โมงตรงนี้ใช่ไหมหานี้ 1
1 ชั่วโมงที่แล้วอันนี้ 2 ชั่วโมงที่
แล้วแล้วก็อันนี้เป็น
3 ชั่วโมงที่แล้วโอเคก็เป็นเวลา
6:00 น 6:00 นอ่ะอ่าโอเคโอเคครับอ่ะ
วันพีชครับ
วันนี้จะเครียดอีกับเรียมจะมาพูดพูดพูด
อ้าวันนี้เราจะมาอ่าบอกที่ดีจะบอกทางให้
น้องเรียมขับรถขับรถมามาบ้านบ้านเปียปี
หนาจะอยากที่จะบอกทางอ๋อ
บ้านของพี่อาร์ตี้อยู่ที่ไหนคะหน้าบ้าน
เพียบที่อยู่ที่อาจจะเทียบที่มีแผนที่อัน
นี้เรียกแผนที่แถมหน้าเป็นแผนที่ได้ครับ
บ้านเพียที่อยู่ตรงนี้มีไหนไหม
โอ้บ้านเทียบที่อยู่ประเทศอะไรคะ R บ้าน
พี่ตี้อยู่ประเทศไทยครับประเภทไทยไส้ค่ะ
หมู่บ้านของพี่อาร์ตี้อยู่จังหวัดอะไรคะ
อยู่จังหวัดนนทบุรี
นนทบุรีครับ
ไม่ให้เชียงใหม่ไม่ใช่พ่อเก็บยางใหม่อ่ะ
ไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯอยู่ติดกับกรุงเทพฯ
กรุงเทพฯกรุงเทพฯอยู่ตรงนี้นนทบุรีอยู่
ติดกันติดกันหน้าบ้านพี่ที่อยู่ติดกับ
กรุงเทพฯนนทบุรีปิดกับกรุงเทพฯ
ใช่ครับบ้านเทียบที่อยู่นนทบุรีทรายขำ
จังหวัดนนทบุรีจังหวัดนนทบุรีใช้ครับ
R  R เดี๋ยวให้น้องเรียมขับรถขับรถมาที่
บ้านเบี้ยแล้วเบี้ยที่จะบอกทางบอกทางนะ
ครับๆที่เค้าวันนี้เตรียมไม่ขับรถยนต์
เนื้อหาเตรียมขับมอเตอร์ไซค์หอค่ะ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้ครับขับมอเตอร์ไซค์ได้เขา
บอกขามอ้า OK ได้ครับเดี๋ยวพี่จะบอกค่ะ
ให้น้องเรียมขับรถไปที่ถนนถนน
รัตนาธิเบศร์ครับอ่าน้องเรียมออกไปที่ถนน
นี่ที่ถนนนาขับไปเรื่อยไปที่ถนน
รัตนาธิเบศร์มีอันนี้คือป้ายเห็นไหมครับ
ตรงนี้ตรงนี้เรียกป้ายๆไหนนนามีดชื่อชื่อ
ถนนอีกนิดถนนถนนรัตนาธิเบศร์นะครับอ่าถนน
ชัยพฤกษ์น้องเรียมมองมองมองหาถนน
รัตนาธิเบศร์
ท่าอิฐรัตนาธิเบศร์ถนนคืออะไรคะอยู่ถนน
คือตรงนี้ครับนี่ตรงนี้นี่คือถนน
ถนนค่า
5 ให้ถนนขับรถตรงไปนี่ถนนขับรถไปบนถนนอะ
ค่ะมอเตอร์ไซค์ใช่ไหมคำขอโทษใสบนโอเค
อ่า
โอเคขับขับตรงไปนะครับน้องเรียมขับตรงไป
ก่อนตรงไปถนนรัตนาธิเบศร์ตรงนี้โอเคนะ
เวลาที่ขับขับตรงไปอันนี้คือคือลูกศรบอก
ให้ลงไปโรงไปหาครับวงลองไปได้ครับขับตรง
ไปไป
ขับตรงไปขับไปขับไปแล้วอะเวลาที่น้อง
เรียมเห็นเห็นวงเวียนครับวงเวียนห้าแบบ
นี้เรียกวงเวียนหาน้องเรียงขับร้องมามามา
นะครับแล้วเจอวงเวียน The  Wall เวียนบง
เวียน
วงเวียนี่ครับนามิวงเวียน cover  thailand
arterial ไม่ต้องวนเทียมขับมาถึงวงเวียน
แล้วให้เขียวเรียมเหลียวครับเลี้ยวขวา
เลี้ยวขวา
เลี้ยวขวา 5 ซ้ายครับเดี๋ยวขวานี้มี
เลี้ยวขวานะป่านนี้เลี้ยวขวาอันนี้เลี้ยว
ซ้ายนะครับให้โรงเรียนเลี้ยวขวาอีกขวานะ
อันนี้นะครับขวาแลต่อไปที่วงเวียนครับพี่
ทำเลี้ยวขวาน้องเรียนจะต้องขับด้านนี้
เวลาขับรถในประเทศไทยในประเทศไทยเราขับรถ
ทิศทางต่างๆหายๆทิศทางอาการศอาญาเดี๋ยว
พี่เปิดถนนในดูนี่ขึ้นก่อนเราต้องกลับทิศ
ทิศทางด้านซ้ายนะครับนักเรียนทิศทางด้าน
ซ้ายน่าใช้ครับโอเคขับคลิปซ้ายแต่ว่า
เดี๋ยวให้น้องเรียมเจอวงเวียนแล้วให้
เลี้ยวขวาใช่ไหมเลี้ยวขวาไอ้ห่านกขวาโอเค
เลี้ยวขวาเนี่ยต้องเลี้ยวมาทางนี้
เลี้ยวขวานี้น่าใช้ครับน้องๆก็ต้องขับทาง
นี้ชิดซ้าย
ชิดซ้ายแล้วก็เลี้ยวขวาใช่ไหมหนาตรงนี้
โอเคโอเคไหมจำได้ไหมครับ
ได้ค่ะรบขวานะโอเคเจ๊ถามเดียวเตรียม
เจอวงเวียนขับวงเวียน
แบบนี้อ่ะ
ถ้าเตรียมก็ขับขับซื่อๆแล้วเลี้ยวขวาตรง
นี้ได้ไหมคะไม่ได้ครับมาฮ่าๆๆฮ่าๆๆฮ่าๆๆ
แล้วเรียนเลี้ยวตรงนี้ไม่ได้ครับเดี๋ยว
ไม่ได้ห้ามเลี้ยวตรงนี้เพราะว่าเพราะว่า
เพราะว่าจะมีคนอื่นคนอื่นมีรถคันอื่น
ร้อนคันอื่นเอาเพชรดีวาดรูปรถคันอื่น
ข้าวมาครั้งนี้เห็นหน้าเราตั้งอยู่ตรงนี้
เข้ามาดังนี้ขับมาดังนี้ถ้าน้องเตรียม
เลี้ยวทั้งนี้อ้าก็จะไปเป็นไงครับชนคนกัน
ทรายชนกันเพราะว่าคันนี้ขับมาทางนี้หาก็
จะชนกันตรงนี้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้น้องเรียนต้อง
คิดทางซ้ายแล้วก็อ้วนไปสุดสายอ้ามีวง
วินซายน์เขารีบบอกบอกเรียมเลี้ยวขวา
หาตรงนี้จะไปตรงนี้ทรายครับ 5 ให้เลี้ยว
ด้านนี้ขออ่ะเดี๋ยวขวา
เตรียมต้องขับตื่น
อ่าขับมาตามทางตรงนี้ครับ
แล้วเลี้ยวขวาสมิขอโอเคค่ะอันนี้โอเคถูก
ต้องแต่ต้องนี้เลี้ยงช่วงนี้มาอีกได้ไม่
ได้โอเคก็จะชน 5 ใช้ครับโอเคครับมาถึงวง
เวียนแล้วก็เลี้ยวขวานะครับอ่าเห็นนะพี่
เปิดแผนที่แผนที่นี่ถึงวงเวียนแล้วใช่ไหม
ครับถึงวงเวียนแล้วก็เลี้ยวขวา
เลี้ยวขวามาเครียดที่ต้องวนงอ่า
สะเก็ S ต้องวนก่อนใช่มั้ยฮะวน 5 เลี้ยว
ขวา
ต่อเขาถึงต้องนะโอเคเดี๋ยวขวาหน้าเวลาไม่
ต้องเรียนเลี้ยวขวามาแล้วเลี้ยวขวามาแล้ว
น้องเรียนก็จะเจอกับเจอกับอะไรคะนี่สถาน
นี้อันนี้เรียกอะไรครับ
เรียก
5 คนไทยคนไทยเรียกไฟแดงใช่คนไทยเรียกไฟ
แดงไฟแดง
เห็นเห็นมีไฟแดง
ไปเหลือก ami ไฟเหลืองไปเขียวก็มีไฟเขียว
ใช่ครับที่ไปแดงมีไฟแดงไปเหลืองไปเขียว
แต่คนไทยคนไทยเรียกสั้นๆก็ได้เทียบไฟแดง
ไม่แดง
ชายแค่ไฟแดงคนไทยไม่ต่อไปเขียวไม่
เรียกไปเหลืองคนไทยมาเห็น
อ่าก็ไหนเรียกไปแดงทั้งหมดก็คือไฟแดงทราย
ทั้งหมดอีกเลี้ยงไฟแดงใช่เหรอแต่ว่าแม่
ที่คนไทยพูดพูดยาวๆวัดสัญญาณไฟจราจร
ชายๆๆจะเป็นอ่า
ยาวเอาเป็นชื่อชื่อชื่อ
จริงชื่อยาวของไฟแดงคือไฟสัญญาณไฟจราจรใจ
ครับหน้าๆบางคนต่ำไม่ได้จำไม่ได้ไม่เรียก
เรียกไฟแดงใช่กลับได้เรียกสั้นๆได้ครับ
สั้นๆไข่แดง
หน้าโอเค
เออไฟแดงคำแต่ถ้าอ้าถ้าไฟแดงไฟแดงติดอยู่
น้องเรียมต้องต้องทำยังไงครับครับไฟแดง
ติดอยู่
หยุดอ้าต้องหยุดใช้ครับจอดจอดนะครับ ru100
จอแล้วก็รอหรอรอต่อ 5 รอให้ไฟแดงดับเป็น
ไฟเขียว
หน้าไปเขียวดิบอาน้องเรียมเกาะไปด่าขับ
ตายครับโอเคอาถึงตรงเดี๋ยวนะเฮียตี้พา
กลับไปดูแผนที่ใหม่นี้นี่แผนที่ตรงนี้จะ
มีไฟแดงอยู่ตรงนี้ครับไฟแดงจะอยู่ตรงนี้
มีไฟแดงอ่ะใช้กับมีสัญญาณไปเจอไฟแดง
เตรียมขับขับตรงไปก็ถูกอา
คายะถูกเพียงดีอยู่ตรงนี้พี่ตี้อยู่ตรง
นี้นี่บ้านพี่อ่ะพี่เห็นไหมอ้าน้องเรียน
จะต้องเลี้ยวครับเลี้ยวเข้าตรงนี้
เลี้ยวซ้าย
อ้าเลี้ยวซ้ายออกไปแดงนะครับขับรถเจอไฟ
แดง
เจอไฟแดงเลี้ยวซ้าย
ถ้าใช้ครับเจอไฟแดงเวลานักเรียนเห็นแสดง
เรียงก็เลี้ยวซ้ายมีเลี้ยวซ้ายใช่ครับ
โอเคค่ะซ้ายเข้าไป
น้านะเดี๋ยวซ้ายเข้าไปมาซ้ายตรงนี้เลี้ยว
ซ้ายเข้าไปแล้วขับตรงไปขับไปตามทางขับไป
ตามทางอยู่ตามทางแบบนี้หน้าทางไปทางไหน
ทางไปทางไหนน้องเรียนก็ขับไปติดตามทางขับ
ๆขับไปตามทางตามทั้งคับทั้งซ้ายนะชิดซ้าย
ทางนี้ขับไม่ได้นะอ่ะต้องขับไปทางนี้น้า
เขาไปทั้งนี้ตามทางซ้ายอาทิตย์ซ้ายตามทาง
ไปตามทางไปเรื่อยๆ
โอเคครั้งเรียนจะเจอจะเจอสามแยกครับ
สามแยกหน้านี้คือป้ายสามแยกนิค่ะอ่า
[เพลง]
1235 มีสามแยกสามแยกแยกใช่ครับอ่าหนู
เลียมขับมาทางนี้อาบมาถาม
เจอสามแยกที่สามแยกสามแยกจะมีจะมีอะ
ซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตชื่อบิ๊กซีมิกซ์
145 หน้าตาแบบนี้ครับนี่บิ๊กซี Big  C
หาถ้าน้องเรียมเห็นเห็นบิ๊กซี Big  C  TM
Big  C และเป็นสามแยกเป็นสามแยกบิ๊กซี
ที่อยู่ตรงนี้นี่ Big  C จะอยู่สามแยกอ่ะ
แสดงว่าน้องเรียมมาถูกแล้วมาถูกแล้วถ้า
บิ๊กซีโอเคอ้าถ้ามีบิ๊กซีโอเคหน้าไอ้น้อง
เรียมขับส่งไปครับรองไปค่ะป้าส่งไปใช่
ครับครับลงไปขับตรงไปตามทางเหมือนเดิมอ้า
ครับลงไปตามทางนะครับตรงไปตามทางอีกขับไป
แล้วน้องเรียนจะเจอสี่แยกครับ
เจอสี่แยกยากอ่ะอันนี้อันนี้เล็กสี่แยก
อ่ะเพราะว่ามีหนึ่งสอบ
4334 นะครับสี่แยกสี่แยกเลี่ยงเธอสี่แยก
อาบขับอ่ะไปทางไหนคะอ้าถ้าเจอสี่แยกแล้ว
ให้เลี้ยวซ้าย
อ่า
เลี้ยวซ้ายก็จะเจอ
หน้าประตูหมู่บ้านประตูหมู่บ้านเป็นประตู
ใหญ่ 5 ขับรถ
ใหญ่มากๆทายครับ 5 ประตูใหญ่มากขับรถเข้า
ไปได้ห่าซ้ายครับมันคิดแล้วก็กรุงประตู
หมู่บ้านนะขับรถเข้าไปหมู่บ้านหมู่บ้าน
หมู่บ้านก็คือที่ที่มีบ้านอยู่เยอะๆนี่มี
บ้านบ้านบ้านๆมีบ้านเยอะมากๆอาริยะหมู่
บ้านร้อนถ้ามีบ้าน
บ้าน 1 หลัง
เรียกหมู่บ้านไหมคะ 5 ถ้าบ้าน 1 หลังไม่
เรียกหมู่บ้านต้องมีบ้านเยอะๆบ้าหลายๆ
ทรายนี่บ้านบ้านๆเรียกหมู่บ้าน
นาว่านครับกู
เราเตรียมต้องขับเข้าไปอ้าใช่ครับขับเข้า
ไปในในหมู่บ้านอาหา
ๆลบบ้านเพียบที่
ตรงไหนคะบ้านพี่อาร์ตี้จะมีเลขที่ครับ
อยู่บ้านเลขที่ 3 ครับน้องเรียมขับเข้ามา
ขับเข้ามาทางประตูเดี๋ยวนะประตูหมู่บ้าน
จะอยู่จะอยู่ด้านนี้โอ้
มาแล้วจะมีหมายเลขหมายเลขเดี๋ยวนะพี่ให้
บ้านเลขที่ใช่ไหมคะอาจจะมีบ้านเลขที่อยู่
ตรงนี้เป็นบ้านเลขที่ตรงนี้อาจจะเป็น 1  2
3 ใช่ครับหลังที่ 1 หลังที่ 2 หลังที่ 3
แบบนี้หน้าบ้านเพียบอิหมายเลข 3
อ่า
มองหามองหาหมายเลข 3 ใต้ใช้ครับ
[เพลง]
เตรียมก็จะฟื้นหาดก็จะถึงบ้าน theatre
ที่
ใจครับเตรียมก็จะเห็นบ้านพี่อาร์ตี้ชาย
เขาหาพี่ก็จะอยู่อยู่อยู่ในบ้านหาอยู่ใน
บ้านถ้าเตรียมต้องไปกดลิงค์ไหมคะหาใช้
หน้าฝากกดติด
อ้าวโอเคสำเร็จแล้ววันนี้น้องเรียนก็มา
ถึงบ้านพี่อ่ะพี่แล้วเคมีนักเรียนคนไหน
นักเรียนมาถึงแล้วครับเลี้ยวสหายเลี้ยว
ขวาไฟแดงลงหรือเปล่ามาถึงพร้อมน้องเรียม
ไหมนะครับง่ายนักเรียนบอกว่า
บ้านบ้านงง theatre ที่อยู่ไหนหลง
หลงหน้าหามั้ย
[เพลง]
อ่าโอเคครับอ่าวันนี้เรามาถึงบ้านพี่
อาร์ตี้แล้วแล้วก็หมดเวลาพอดีนะครับ
เดี๋ยวอ่าข้าวหน้าคราวหน้าเรามาดูกันว่า
เราจะมาเรียนอะไรกันเพราะวันนี้น้องเรียน
มาที่บ้านพี่อาร์ตี้แล้วโอเคโอเคครับ 5
เตรียมจะไปมากินข้าวที่บ้านที่บ้านพี่
อาร์ตี้ใช่มั้ยได้เลยครับ
โอเคอ่าเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเรากลับมาเจอกัน
ใหม่ครับในช่องคอมเพรนเซเบิลไทยนะครับวัน
นี้เพียงตี้แล้วก็น้องเรียมนะครับ
ไปก่อนครับบ๊ายบายฮ่าๆๆสวัสดีค่ะพี่นัก
เรียนมดังนี้ดิ
บ๊ายบายสวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนม